devait atterrir et ben tu vas attacher
nos ceinture donc après il y avait des
turbulences et après je sais plus
nous sommes le 30 juin 2009 vers 1h30 du
matin le vol 626 de la Yémenia Airlines
s'écrase en pleine mer au large des
côtes de l'archipel des Comores
on les utilise pour voyager pour
s'évader pour rejoindre ce qu'on aime
mais il arrive que rien ne se passe
comme prévu
parfois l'avion dans lequel on vole
s'écrase c'est rarissime mais lorsqu'on
vit une telle épreuve et qu'on en
réchappe commence en remettre
[Musique]
Thibault a perdu sa compagne lors du
crash d'un avion à Phuket lui a survécu
Baya aussi a survécu un crash c'est même
la seule survivante du vol des Comores
j'ai eu envie de les rencontrer pour
qu'il me raconte comment ce qui
ressemble à un miracle peut devenir une
épreuve difficile à vivre
je m'appelle Thibault lamerge j'ai 28
ans je suis survivant du crash aérien de
Phuket le 16 septembre 2007 je m'appelle
Daya bakkary j'ai 16 ans je suis la
rescapé des crashs des Comores
ce devait être au départ de simples
vacances pour Thibault et Bahia un
moment de bonheur aux côtés de ce qu'ils
aiment mais le destin en a voulu
autrement les avions dans lesquels ils
voyager se sont un jour écrasés
s'ils ont survécu à ces catastrophes
aériennes chacun y a perdu un être cher
depuis ce traumatisme il tente de se
reconstruire et tout simplement de vivre
[Musique]
cet album est le témoignage de la vie
passée de Thibault Lamère
à ses côtés sur ses photos Laetitia sa
compagne de l'époque
on avait prévu d'acheter un appartement
elle avait arrêté la pilule enfin on
avait prévu de faire des enfants et puis
se marier nous sommes en 2007 les deux
tourtereaux font alors des projets
d'avenir et viennent de s'offrir un
séjour en amoureux en Thaïlande
vous allez voir c'est
c'est paradisiaque et tout c'est joli
paradis se transforme en cauchemar
tout commence en décembre 2016 alors que
Thibault et sa fiancée Laetitia sont en
vacances en Thaïlande
on a fait d'abord une semaine de tours
de la Thaïlande et nous à la base on
devait aller à Pattaya et le guide nous
a proposé de de changer de destination
de partir sur Phuket parce qu'il nous a
dit vous verrez là-bas c'est super c'est
une île paradisiaque on a dit oui au
guide on a dit d'accord prenez-nous les
prenez nous les billets réservez nous
pour pouvoir partir là-bas
Laetitia et Thibault embarquent à Phuket
avec 128 autres passagers destination
Bangkok mais juste avant le départ
Thibault qui a quelques connaissances en
aéronautique remarque certains détails
étranges je me souviens qu'au moment
juste avant l'embarquement il tient
c'est marrant ça faisait c'était quand
même un vieil un vieil avion parce que
les MD80 ils datent des années justement
des années 80 enfin peut-être 78 je
crois les premiers
non seulement l'appareil est obsolète
mais en plus les conditions météo
deviennent de plus en plus menaçantes
Thibault commence alors à angoisser à
ses côtés sa compagne tente de le
rassurer
au fur et à mesure du volley les nuages
de plus en plus gris et même le ciel
vraiment noir on avait un peu de
turbulences l'avion était ballotté un
peu de droite à gauche ça faisait un peu
les montagnes russes elle m'a donné la
main et elle m'a dit non mais t'inquiète
pas c'est normal et tout à chaque minute
qui passe les conditions de vol empire
et les efforts de Laetitia pour calmer
son
avion là décroché de mes passer de 100
pieds à 50 pieds et 2 secondes après en
fait l'avion touchait le sol la l'avion
accélère et on se plante
l'appareil vient de s'écraser au bout de
quelques minutes Thibault reprend
conscience autour de lui c'est le chaos
je sais pas exactement combien de temps
j'ai été inconscient mais quand je me
réveille en fait je suis toujours assise
sur mon siège parce que je me souviens
je me suis décroché j'ai essayé j'ai
aussi retirer la scie j'ai dégager tout
ce qu'il y avait autour de moi pour
chercher Laetitia et devant moi ça fait
comme un ravin en fait et enfin il y a
une fausse et il y a plein de débris il
y a des morceaux de de cordes de
personnes j'entends des gens qui
agonisent tout et la personne qui était
en dessous moi ma droite était brune
elle était pas les tiettes et blonde et
la personne à ma droite était brune
j'essaie d'appeler deux trois fois au
secours en me rendant compte que il
m'entendent pas il y a beaucoup trop de
bruit une pensée que j'ai eu c'est
je suis encore vivant et je vais mourir
brûlé parce que derrière je sentais la
chaleur du feu et les fumes est toxiques
je me dis je suis enfin j'ai pas réussi
à sortir quoi c'est c'est un cauchemar
je sais pas réussir à m'en sortir mais
Thibault et grièvement blessé mais il
arrive tout de même à trouver la force
de hurler pour qu'on vienne le sauver
tabasser dans la reprise
quand la tête mais j'avais pas mal
j'avais pas mes jambes j'ai sentais plus
en fait la douleur était telle que le
corps est tellement bien fait que bah la
douleur il l'a zappé
lorsque les secours arrivent ils
entendent ces cris et parviennent à le
dégager il est immédiatement transporté
à l'hôpital de Phuket là après un examen
poussé le diagnostic tombe
en fracture ils en ont répertorié à peu
près 85 il y avait luxation au niveau de
la hanche enfin des deux hanches les
genoux démentibués j'avais côtes pour
mon père-forêt le nez cassé la mâchoire
une fracture à la main et c'est tout ce
que j'avais pour le haut du corps et
après le reste le reste des fractures
c'était en dessous des en dessous les
genoux sur tibia et péroné la jambe
droite et de la jambe gauche
[Musique]
vous êtes journaliste et spécialiste des
questions aéronautiques on a pour
coutume de dire que l'avion est le moyen
de transport le plus sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de morts dans les
accidents de voiture pourtant avec le
développement du trafic aérien et les
accidents qui se sont multipliés est-ce
que c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
l'avion est toujours et de loin le moyen
de transport le plus sûr devant le train
devant l'automobile bien sûr devant la
moto enfin devant tous les autres moyens
de transport et l'avion lui-même est de
plus en plus sûr il y a 25 ans 30 ans
lorsqu'on transportait seulement un
milliard de passagers par an le
dirigeant de Boeing le patron de Boeing
disait que au taux actuel c'est à dire à
l'époque de développement du transport
aérien si on n'arrivait pas à réduire le
nombre d'accidents en statistique il y
aurait un avion qui s'écraserait chaque
semaine et à l'époque il y en avait
10-15 par an 25 30 ans après on
transporte 2 milliards et demi de
passagers par an il y a trois quatre
graves accidents par an 2 3 qui font
beaucoup de morts et donc on a divisé
par 30 ou par 40 le nombre des accidents
d'avion et c'est un record considérable
aujourd'hui si on veut parler de la
sécurité du transport aérien on parle de
quelque chose qui est très mince c'est
l'épaisseur du trait et pourtant il faut
faire des progrès car c'est vraiment un
moyen de transport qui tend vers le
risque zéro
[Musique]
Thibault Lamaire rescapé du crash de
Phuket et dans un état critique mais il
est vivant malheureusement on reste
toujours sans nouvelles de sa compagne
[Musique]
vit à Corbeil-Essonnes une petite
commune tranquille dans la banlieue
parisienne cet adolescente de 16 ans est
une bonne élève qui s'apprête à rentrer
en première S comme toutes les jeunes
filles de son âge elle passe beaucoup de
temps sur les réseaux sociaux à chatter
avec ses copines bref c'est une ado
comme toutes les autres enfin presque
car bien qu'elle soit aujourd'hui en vie
et en bonne santé Baya est une véritable
miraculée
pour elle tout a basculé lors de l'été
2009 la jeune fille a alors 13 ans cette
année-là elle a prévu de prendre l'avion
avec sa maman ensemble elles doivent se
rendre à un mariage familial au Comores
on prend le vol à Paris il fait une
escale à Marseille on arrive à Sana on
change d'avion pour aller à moins le
début du voyage se déroule sans encombre
et pourtant déjà Baya n'est pas vraiment
sereine
[Musique]
un malaise qui ne fait qu'augmenter
lorsqu'elles embarquent sur le vol en
transit vers les Comores l'appareil de
la Yemenia Airlines semble ne pas
respecter toutes les normes d'hygiène
[Musique]
on voit des mouches et les hôtesses
pour l'odeur des toilettes personnes je
me suis dit ça doit être comme ça
pourtant malgré ces conditions
hygiéniques déplorables le vol se
déroule normalement
jusqu'au moment où l'appareil entame la
procédure d'atterrissage
devait atterrir et une petite attacher
nos ceintures donc après il y avait des
turbulences et après je sais plus
nous sommes le 30 juin 2009 vers 1h30 du
matin le vol 626 de la Yemenia Airlines
s'écrase en pleine mer au large des
côtes de l'archipel des Comores
à 8000 km de là Kassim le père de Bayard
reçoit un coup de fil au beau milieu de
la nuit
c'est une copine
tu m'as appelé à
3h42 je me rappellerai toujours et c'est
là qu'il m'a dit ouvre la télé tu
regardes et c'est là j'ai appris le
nouvel comme quoi l'avion est disparu
dans les écrans en commun
toujours le pire parce que c'est un truc
personne n'est pas préparé pour ça alors
que son père est en train de se
morfondre Bayard reprend conscience il
fait nuit elle dérive en pleine mer sur
un débris de l'appareil et n'a aucun
souvenir de l'accident
est tombé tomber il y a pas eu
d'accident
je suis assez tombé je sais pas comment
Bahia est perdu en pleine mer elle croit
être toute seule mais elle se trompe
et je voyais personne autour de moi
j'étais toute seule j'entendais des
bruits de femmes crier c'est des crêtes
de souffrance un peu bah vu ils
entendent je me suis mis à crier genre
faut les appeler à l'aide mais personne
ne va répondre à son appel la mère
déchaînée aura raison des derniers
autres survivants il ne passeront pas la
nuit
paniquez et blessé Baya ne peut compter
que sur elle-même le mélange de l'eau
salée le kérosène c'est pas très bon et
je pouvais pas éviter parce que je
prenais les vagues sur moi donc ça rend
très forcément même si je fermais la
bouche j'ai touché mon visage au bout
d'un moment j'ai senti que mon oeil
gauche il était contré mais sinon à part
ça je sentais pas j'avais des brûlures
aux pieds et tout et je sentais rien du
tout j'étais choquée surtout ça j'avais
peur un peu aussi
et après je me suis endormie Bahia sera
la seule survivante d'une des plus
terribles catastrophes aérienne du 21e
siècle
vous êtes expert en sûreté aérienne
quelles sont les causes les plus
fréquentes dans les catastrophes
aériennes il y a deux causes principales
il y a d'abord la cause accidentelle
99% des cas
en ce qui concerne les crashs aériens et
puis il y a la cause intentionnelle les
problématiques de sûreté liées aux
attentats dans le domaine aérien c'est
très très rare et
c'est ce qui est le moins mortel si
j'ose dire mais elles font partie des
catastrophes qui marquent le plus elles
font partie des catastrophes qui
marquent le plus parce que justement on
a l'impression que cette volonté de tuer
c'est exprimée en fait sur des gens qui
étaient totalement innocents le meilleur
moyen de lutter contre le terrorisme
aérien c'est de continuer de prendre
l'avion et de ne pas arrêter l'activité
aérienne c'est très compliqué évidemment
à faire comprendre aux clients mais
c'est pourtant la seule chose qui
fonctionne il y a pourtant les
journalistes qui montrent qu'ils peuvent
passer les parties avec une arme il y a
beaucoup de journalistes qui démontrent
qu'il y a effectivement
des failles dans le dispositif
aujourd'hui actuel qui est un dispositif
qui est basé sur le contrôle des objets
le problème c'est que les objets par
eux-mêmes ils sont inertes là les deux
verres d'eau qui sont là sont énerves ne
vont pas se renverser tout seul quand il
y a un attentat c'est forcément un acte
qui est intentionnelle et donc on se
trompe de cible c'est pas les objets
qu'il faut contrôler c'est les personnes
et notamment leur identité
est perdu en pleine mer au milieu de
vagues de 3 mètres le combat est inégal
et à cet instant précis ses chances de
survie semblent un film
mais un coup de pouce du destin va
pourtant venir changer la donne
[Musique]
Thibault Lamère fait partie des 40
rescapés du crash Bangkok
il est le seul des 10 passagers français
à avoir survécu mais lorsqu'il arrive à
l'hôpital son état est particulièrement
critique
pour regarder quand j'étais au bloc ce
qui pouvait faire et puis là il m'a dit
il faudrait qu'on
faudrait qu'on vous transfère sur
Bangkok parce que l'hôpital de Phuket on
n'est pas assez bien équipé pour pour
essayer de vous soigner la jambe parce
qu'au final j'étais en train de essayer
de faire une infection et ma jambe était
en train de se goniner donc un moment de
chirurgien tu es même en train de se
dire là ça peut être la dernière
opération après on va être obligé de
couper la jambe donc je suis plus à ça
près
me dit c'est rien c'est qu'un bout de
champ après tout c'est
on peut quand même marcher avec une
jambe de moins donc je me dis
il faut couper il faut couper c'est
je suis pas attaché à mon corps plus
spécialement que ça quoi étant donné son
état de santé les médecins jugent qu'il
est trop tôt pour annoncer à Thibault la
terrible nouvelle
sa fiancée Laetitia n'a pas survécu dans
un premier temps on m'a dit que Laeticia
il a
il l'avait pas retrouvé après on m'a dit
qu'elle était dans le même état que moi
donc il fallait que je macroche pour
enfin pour qu'il fallait que se
m’accroche parce que mon pronostic vital
était comme engagé ça avait pas si mon
cœur tiendrait le coup ou pas mais
Thibault va comprendre ce qui s'est
réellement passé lorsque la mère de
Laetitia arrive effondrée à Phuket et
j'ai compris qui a été décédé quand j'ai
vu sa mère au bout d'une semaine avant
d'être transféré sur sur Bangkok parce
que mon état s'améliorait pas
transférer à Bangkok les médecins
parviennent à sauver la jambe de
Thibault mais la nouvelle du décès de sa
compagne est un choc terrible malgré son
rétablissement il est anéanti il n'a que
25 ans mais il n'a déjà plus goût à la
vie
on m'a un peu shooté avant de avant de
remonter dans l'avion
m'ont donné un médicament pour me sentir
mieux et puis
au moment de l'atterrissage j'ai pas
voulu prendre je me suis dit après tout
on s'en fout par terre c'est pas grave
[Musique]
Serge vous êtes psychiatre est-ce que
c'est ce genre de témoignage qui
renforce la peur de l'avion chez les
gens bah oui d'abord tout le monde a un
peu peur de l'avion même ceux qui disent
qu'ils en ont pas peur il y a toujours
ce moment un peu compliqué quand on
quand un avion décolle mais alors en
plus entendre des personnes qui parlent
de ça qui sont dans le témoignage de ça
bien évidemment ça ça ravive très
fortement ses peurs d'où elle vient
cette peur vous savez il y a quelque
chose d'un peu prométhéin de s'envoler
dans les airs l'homme ne vole pas a
priori donc il est là il est au-dessus
du sol et il y a c'est pas les mythes
qui manquent de la chute d'Icare par
exemple il est puni par les dieux parce
qu'il a voulu s'élever dans les airs
donc il y a de façon assez irrationnelle
quelque chose dans l'inconscient
collectif qui est que un homme ne vole
pas voilà c'est pas un oiseau et que
s'il le fait et bien il défie en quelque
sorte l'ordre naturel ou l'ordre divin
est-ce qu'il est possible de s'en
débarrasser de cette peur ou est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on garde à vie
alors si c'est une vraie phobie des
avions c'est une vraie peur il y a des
techniques de désensibilisation il y a
des méthodes petit à petit qui vous
apprennent à apprendre à monter dans un
avion à supporter l'altitude donc on
peut on peut être désensibilisé
[Musique]
cela fait maintenant plusieurs heures
que Baya Bakari dérive sur son débris de
carlingue le jour se lève et elle est
toujours toute seule en pleine mer et le
réveil le matin il fait jour il y a
toujours faire ça ne trouvez moi et je
suis toujours accrochée à une épave je
voyais une île au loin donc moi je me
suis dit
[Musique]
sauf que avec la mer qui était agitée
oui je pense à ma famille mes amis et je
me dis je suis petite quand même j'ai
pas fait grand-chose de ma vie
et il m'arrive ça de mourir dans l'eau
toute seule alors que Baya vient de
passer 9 heures dans l'eau l'inespérée
se produit un bateau de pêche la repère
et la sauve
pas bien à aller jusqu'au bateau il me
lance une bouée et j'arrive pas à
l'attraper donc il y a un homme qui
descend pour m'aider à la prendre et
monter dans le bateau
aussitôt transféré à l'hôpital Baya n'a
pas encore conscience de ce qui vient de
se passer si c'est bon je suis sauvée je
vais retrouver ma famille et c'est bon
c'est je vais faire le enfin à ce moment
là je sentais vraiment pas mes blessures
j'avais vraiment pas mal donc
j'ai dit c'est bon j'ai vu monsieur il
me suffit de me reposer et après je vais
vivre mes vacances tranquillement comme
c'était prévu
ce que Baya ne s'est pas encore c'est
que sa mère et tous les autres passagers
sont morts
les médecins ne savent pas comment
annoncer la terrible nouvelle à la jeune
fille sans risquer de la traumatiser
oui ça va après je lui demande oui ma
mère et elle me dit comme quoi je suis
la seule qu'on a retrouvé pour l'instant
et qu'on n'est pas on n'a pas encore
retrouvé ma mère et qu'elle pense pas
qu'on va la retrouver mais pour moi on
avait tous été retrouvé
pas les autres on était dans le même
avion ils auraient dû tomber
est sauvé mais son état de santé n'en
reste pas moins préoccupant
parce que j'ai des brûlures au pied
au niveau du coude aussi
je sais pas il y a une irritation et ça
fait que mon oeil il allait s'enfoncer
donc il fallait qu'on l'opère pour pas
que
s'enfonce rien derrière
[Musique]
c'est une miraculée elle s'appelle Bahia
Bakary elle a 13 ans et elle a survécu
seule au crash de l'Airbus quelques
heures après son sauvetage le drame de
l'accident est le miracle de la survie
de Bahia font la une de tous les
journaux
des coupures au visage et une simple
clavicule cassée après le crash voici
Baya sur son nid de l'hôpital de Moroni
elle a survécu pendant une dizaine
d'heures accrochées à un débris d'avion
Baya qui a perdu sa maman à temps
maintenant de voir son père qui doit
arriver de France
[Musique]
Baya est prise d'assaut par des
journalistes qu'il a harcèlent pour
obtenir une interview pour la jeune
fille c'est une épreuve à laquelle elle
n'était pas préparée
j'étais prêt à tout il y a un monsieur
je fais pas un interview avec elle moi
je voulais qu'on me laisse tranquille à
ce moment là qu'on vienne tout le temps
en bas de chez moi
donc j'ai pas l'habitude que tous les
regards ils sont posés sur moi
vu que j'ai dû apprendre à gérer ça
[Musique]
car j'ai fait on se rend compte qu'il y
a à la fois la peur et également une
forme de fascination du public face aux
accidents d'avion on peut le constater
avec le nombre de films éventuellement
qui qu'il y a sur ces accidents d'avion
il y a dans l'avion dans le fait de se
trouver dans un avion le fait de
remettre son destin à quelqu'un qui est
le pilote de cette de cet avion qui est
le fait qu'il va pas y avoir de
terroristes ou de méchantes personnes
pour détourner votre donc comment dire
on est plus maître de soi voilà une fois
qu'on est assis dans son siège on est
comme un nourrisson sur son petit siège
bébé c'est à dire que on est totalement
dépossédé de soit une voiture on peut
l'arrêter on peut descendre un train on
peut tirer la sonnette d'alarme on peut
on peut aussi en descendre l'avion il y
a rien à faire c'est très régressif et
oui c'est très très agressif et
d'ailleurs on le sent bien quand on est
dans l'avion là on vous nourrit on vous
donne des plateaux vous dormez vous
regardez des films c'est un univers
totalement clos et et on est on est
totalement vrai finalement aux hôtesses
au steward au pilote et à ceux qui vous
entourent donc le fait que ça soit un
univers régressif ça vous remet aussi
dans cet état d'esprit d'enfant dans des
peurs d'enfants éventuellement dans des
angoisses beaucoup plus infantiles ou
aussi dans d'autres États infantiles de
plaisir de toute puissance de il
m'arrivera rien chacun y réagit un peu
comme il veut
après avoir été rapatriés en France
Thibault Lamaire séjournera dans divers
hôpitaux après plusieurs opérations il
pourra à nouveau retrouver partiellement
l'usage de ses jambes
persil Garges compris
avec les délais des opérations chez du
rester près d'un an à l'hôpital
Thibault alterne les séjours à l'hôpital
en rééducation et les séjours ici dans
la maison de son père
[Musique]
dans le dans le salon
et là j'avais là j'avais mon lit avec
une petite armoire pour ranger mes
affaires quand on revient chez ses
parents enfin lâcher mon père c'est pas
c'était parti c'était déjà compliqué
quand je suis parti donc c'était pas
forcément plus simple de revenir que
[Musique]
en fait dans la dans la maison en fait
pour aller aux toilettes on retire le
voilà on retire et puis on nous glisse
en fait au dessus du toilette pour faire
ses besoins
lourdement handicapé et dépendant des
autres Thibault n'est plus alors que
l'ombre de lui-même pourtant en mars
2008 il fait une rencontre qui va tout
changer celle de Julie une jeune
ergothérapeute qui travaille dans le
centre où il est en rééducation
tiens mon cœur tu vas m'aider s'il te
plaît
je suis un peu en galère
c'est un petit centre de rééducation à
Richebourg et on connaissait à peu près
tous les patients tout en qu'on
connaisse son histoire parce qu'elle
était quand même particulière rescapé
d'un crash aérien avec la perte de sa
compagne donc histoire assez dramatique
pour marquer donc on connaissait son cas
on connaissait aussi son histoire mais
aussi en fait ce qu'il était parce que
c'était un personnage quand même assez
particulier au sein de du centre de
rééducation puisque il était une colère
importante ou jamais rien à aller ou je
crois que la première phrase que je lui
ai dit c'est avec toi on n'a pas droit à
l'erreur quoi quand je la rencontre
[Musique]
c'était dans une pulsion de vie donc
faut pour essayer d'avancer
d'avancer quoi c'est c'est vrai que je
recommence à marcher et tout donc de
nouveau je trouvais quelqu'un sur qui
compter sur qui me reposait et sur
qu'est-ce qu'on faisait
grâce à Julie Thibault fait rapidement
des progrès et semble à nouveau
reprendre goût à la vie
psychologiquement il était dans une
phase de toute-puissance dans les
rescapés craché à rien généralement il y
a une phase de taux de puissance de je
suis pas mort avec ça donc je suis je
suis tout-puissant rien ne peut
m'arriver petit à petit avec l'aide de
sa nouvelle compagne Thibault Lamaire
parvient à se reconstruire en 2010 ils
deviennent les heureux parents d'une
petite Elena
[Musique]
continuer à vivre on va dire jusqu'à
quand on est le goût de la vie
[Musique]
mais je pense qu'il en est très content
enfin il dit c'est c'est un rayon de
soleil c'est même quand on va pas bien
on est obligé d'aller bien parce que
quand elle nous sourit c'est formidable
mais je pense qu'il peut pas être
complètement heureux voilà même avec
Elena
car malgré ce bonheur familial les
fantômes de son passé ne sont jamais
très loin les parents Laetitia dans leur
souffrance en fait ont mal réagi face à
face au fait qu'il soit de nouveau avec
quelqu'un et que ce soit sérieux donc du
coup face à leur réactions négatives
lui c'est c'est dit je dois faire
quelque chose de mal ou c'est pas je
suis bien et en même temps je devrais
pas faire ça donc il s'est mis dans une
culpabilité en fait je pense que le
babilitée qu'il a toujours
la campagne de Thibault vient d'évoquer
le syndrome du survivant en quoi ça
consiste c'est le fait que le destin
frappe de façon un peu aveugle il frappe
celui qui était ou celle qui est à côté
de vous et pas vous et c'est vrai que
s'il y a quelque chose de là de
tellement irrationnel que on est obligé
de lui donner du sens vous savez
l'esprit humain et pas tellement les
choses irrationnelles il doit trouver
des interprétations et du sens un petit
peu à tout même à ce qu'il en a pas et
donc le syndrome du survivant c'est de
se demander d'être obsédé par cette
question pourquoi elle est pas moi
pourquoi l'autre et pourquoi pas moi et
de trouver les réponses qui sont parfois
des réponses assez folles à cette
question qui est qu'on a été épargné
quand on a échappé
à un événement collectif où les autres
ont été atteints voire où tous les
autres ont été atteints on est le seul
survivant c'est tellement énorme que on
peut passer le restant de ces jours à
essayer de se demander pourquoi moi j'ai
été choisi pourquoi j'ai été élu
qu'est-ce qui me caractérise qui donne
du sens à cette histoire insensée qui
m'est arrivé du coup ça consiste en quoi
on se sent super puissant ou ça peut
être soit que ça se retourne contre soi
sous forme de culpabilité c'est à dire
je ne méritais pas ça c'était l'autre
qui méritait de survivre et pas moi et
donc c'est cette culpabilité qui va vous
écraser soit effectivement un sentiment
de toute puissance qui est voilà je suis
invincible tous les autres sont mortels
mais moi je suis beaucoup plus fort que
et d'ailleurs là est souvent le revers
de l'autre c'est un peu le revers de la
même médaille on peut passer de l'un à
l'autre la culpabilité c'est inéluctable
lorsqu'on échappe un accident c'est
difficile de l'éviter surtout si
quelqu'un de proche
a disparu à côté de vous quelqu'un de
proche on se dit que peut-être qu'on
aurait pu le protéger peut-être qu'on
aurait pu faire quelque chose pour
empêcher ça peut-être qu'on n'a pas fait
tout ce qu'il était possible pour
empêcher l'événement même si c'est
totalement irrationnel on peut être
traversé par ces idées là évidemment
est une miraculée la Providence lui a
offert une seconde chance malgré tout
pour elle la vie ne pourra plus jamais
être comme avant car Aziza sa maman
n'est plus là
chanter à sa présence elle était pas là
et après ouais j'ai pleuré il doit y
avoir à mon père et voilà c'est à ce
moment là vraiment que j'ai ressenti
son absence
une absence très dure à supporter pour
Baya mais aussi pour ses frères et sœurs
à peu près maman
quand ils viennent dans la chambre je
trouve que papa et là c'est tout de
suite dans la tête c'est Maman qui
viendra la tête
moi aussi quand je viens dans ma chambre
je dis à ma femme qui est là et quand je
viens c'est tout de suite dans la tête
c'est l'enchaînement de tout mais il
faut dire voilà mais il va falloir que
je y aller il va falloir gérer ça
[Musique]
depuis que sa maman n'est plus là Baya
la grande soeur a dû prendre ses
responsabilités pour aider son père elle
s'occupe de ses frères et sœurs et en
particulier du petit dernier Badaoui
j'ai pas envie qu'il arrive quelque
chose de mal donc je fais toujours
attention à eux oui je suis plus mature
que la plupart des films
ils sont dans un monde
est-ce que ma frange elle est bien
droite ou à mon vernis pas trop c'est
pas mal mis et mon mascara est comparé
des choses plus importantes dans la vie
dépêche-toi aujourd'hui pour Baya les
priorités se sont d'abord ses études son
objectif devenir médecin généraliste
mais pour faire des études il faut de
l'argent pour l'aider Sophie beauté son
avocate se bat pour que la jeune fille
obtienne une réparation à la hauteur du
préjudice subi
nous suivons cette affaire évidemment au
point de vue indemnitaire et puis
afin que
Baya et sa famille puissent être
normalement dignement indemnisé alors
moi de mon côté j'ai également actionné
la voici vide où j'ai déjà eu quelques
résultats effectivement
notamment sur des mises en place de
rente pour les enfants le crash des
Comores a fait 158 victimes
avari matériel
erreur humaine aujourd'hui l'enquête
pour déterminer les responsables et dans
une impasse
Michel polaco dans l'affaire du vol de
la Yémenia le Yémen semble rejeter la
faute sur l'armée française via une
dépêche de l'agence de presse
gouvernementale indique quand que
l'avion a pu être touché par un missile
français qu'en est-il alors l'accident
de la viande Yémenia qui s'est produit
on approche de nuit au Comores est un
accident pour lequel le rapport officiel
n'a jamais été publié le rapport n'est
pas publié parce que les milliers
menhies refusent de collaborer il refuse
de collaborer parce que c'est un avion
yéméni piloté par des yéménite qui est
en cause dans la catastrophe et que
c'est
la procédure appliquée par l'équipage
qui est à l'origine de cette catastrophe
ça s'est produit de nuit avec un vent
fort l'avion a fait une approche avec le
vent arrière sur un système d'aide à
l'atterrissage de nuit puis ensuite en
vue de la piste il s'est éloigné en mer
pour revenir se poser en sens inverse
face au vent c'est dans cette phase là
que l'équipage a sans doute perdu ses
références à toucher la mer et que la
violence est écrasée donc il bien
évident que c'est pas l'avion qui est en
cause éventuellement on pourrait dire
que la l'aéroport des Comores n'est pas
très bien équipé mais il y en a d'autres
comme ça dans le monde en revanche
l'équipage est donc la compagnie des
médias sont encoreus le Yémen ne
souhaite pas être obligé de payer des
indemnités au passagers aux ayant droit
des passagers et par conséquent il fait
traîner c'est une attitude qui est non
conforme aux règles internationales et
la Convention de Chicago qui régit la
sécurité du transport aérien ça peut
durer longtemps il y a d'autres pays qui
procèdent ainsi donc l'histoire du
missile c'est à l'heure histoire du
missile ne tient pas debout il y aura
absolument aucun élément qui permettent
ni de près ni de loin d'imaginer que ce
soit un missile et d'ailleurs si c'était
un missile ça n'aurait pas du tout eu
les mêmes effets que ce qui s'est
produit et que quand on a tous les
éléments puisque vous savez qu'on a
repêché les boîtes noires qu'on a
repêché sur ces éléments de l'avion et
que il y avait des témoins aussi de
l'approche de l'avion lorsqu'il a
commencé à aller commencer à apparaître
sur la piste de l'aéroport des Comores
de Moroni
trois ans après le crash des Comores
sans vrais explications et sans réel
excuses les familles des victimes se
battent pour qu'on n'oublie pas la
mémoire de ceux qu'elles ont perdu
un sentiment d'injustice que partage
Baya
elle souhaite entretenir le souvenir de
ceux qui n'ont pas eu comme elle la
chance de s'en sortir
pour leur rendre hommage elle compte
retourner aux Comores
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années Thibault Lamaire
lutte pour pouvoir retrouver son
intégrité physique et une meilleure
autonomie un combat qui passe par de
multiples opérations chirurgicales avant
la dernière opération que j'ai eu pour
redresser la jambe gauche ma chambre
était concrètement elle était comme ça
quoi ils ont fait un triangle et puis
après ils ont joué sur l'élasticité de
l'os ils ont redressé puis ils m'ont mis
une plaque pour verrouiller pour
verrouiller aujourd'hui c'est son
premier rendez-vous chez cet ostéopathe
après avoir pris connaissance de son
dossier médical elle lui fait faire une
série de tests physiologiques
et on y va on pousse encore contre moi
vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y
et on relâche on relâche-la est-ce que
c'est douloureux tu vois
ok on relâche on va faire autre chose
même si le travail est très bien fait et
qui gagne en mobilité au niveau de tes
articulations jamais ils retrouvera 100%
de mobilité ou de sensibilité au niveau
de ses tissus comme si rien de s'était
passé et on va tester la respiration
travailler au niveau du diaphragme donc
vous allez prendre une inspiration
allez-y voilà et on monte jusqu'en haut
et on expire à fond il est là il est
positif et tout mais il y a quand même
quelque chose dans lui qui est qui est
tendu et ça il faut il faut l'exprimer
aussi pour que pour qu'il s'en
débarrasse une fois pour toute à bientôt
bon courage et
bonne bon rétablissement le malaise de
Thibault n'est pas seulement physique il
est aussi psychologique
il ressent aujourd'hui de la colère
contre la compagnie d'aviation à
l'origine de l'accident avec les
familles des passagers français qui sont
morts dans le crash ils ont créé une
association
Gérard BEM baron a perdu son frère ce
jour-là avocat de profession il est
logiquement devenu le président de cette
association
je considère que les défaillances de la
compagnie sont déjà avérés au travers du
rapport d'enquête administratif qui
révèle un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnement du d'une gravité
importante et dysfonctionnement qui à
mon sens devrait être suffisant pour
mettre en examen le dirigeant de cette
compagnie aérienne et le convoquer
des rapports semblent avoir mis en
lumière les nombreuses lacunes de la
compagnie thaïlandaise au niveau de la
maintenance des appareils mais aussi au
niveau du temps de travail du personnel
navigant en dépit de tous ces éléments
cette filiale de la taille Airways
continue d'exercer et famille avait
obtenu l'inscription de la compagnie sur
la liste noire de la Communauté
européenne
ce qui était pour nous quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et en réalité à
la suite d'un jeu de passe-passe auquel
se sont prêtés les autorités européennes
pour des motifs vraisemblablement
d'opportunités diplomatiques qui nous
dépasse terriblement ce blacklistage on
aura duré que quelques mois aujourd'hui
la compagnie impliquée dans le crash a
de nouveaux pignons sur rue et le drame
de 2007 semble naître plus qu'un
lointain souvenir
c'est pour cette raison que même si cela
lui est douloureux Thibault veut malgré
tout continuer à parler de ce qui s'est
passé
si on veut derrière que ça avance
de faire le maximum quoi pour essayer de
mettre sensibiliser un peu les gens leur
dire quand vous partez en Thaïlande
c'est vrai c'est un pays très beau les
gens sont très accueillants et tout mais
enfin faites bien sûr quoi vous voulez
quoi on vous ment
Christophe Naudin on trouve sur la liste
noire de la Communauté européenne près
de 300 compagnies aériennes dont la très
grande majorité africaine en préambule
de la liste noire la Communauté
européenne précise il n'est pas possible
de contrôler tous les avions qui
atterrissent en Europe le fait qu'une
compagnie aérienne ne figure pas sur la
liste communautaire ne signifie donc pas
automatiquement qu'elle respecte les
normes de sécurité c'est plutôt
inquiétant cette inquiétant mais c'est
la vérité donc là on peut pas reprocher
à notre administration à savoir le
ministère des Transports et plus
spécifiquement la Direction générale de
l'aviation civile de ne pas être
transparent c'est une déclaration qui
est très transparente et très vraie mais
elle sert à quoi cette elle sert à
indiquer commercialement aux gens que il
est pas forcément une bonne idée de
contracter avec un voyagiste qui va
utiliser des compagnies aériennes qui
sont blacklistés ou quand on est à
l'étranger puisque les compagnies
blacklistés souvent ne peuvent pas venir
en Europe
quand vous êtes à l'étranger il est pas
toujours très malin d'utiliser des
compagnies qui ont une mauvaise
réputation pour faire des trajets on va
dire intérieurs on peut pas payer
le prix d'un voyage aérien
la même chose qu'une place de cinéma je
veux dire il y a une valeur pour chaque
chose quand on vous propose d'aller pour
25 euros l'autre côté de l'Europe alors
où c'est une super promotion qui est
fait par une compagnie très sérieuse
mais il y a trois places dans un avion
qui en fait 200 ou alors c'est que c'est
pas possible c'est qu'on a renié sur un
centre de facteurs dont les facteurs de
sécurité donc c'est plus dangereux il
faut se méfier il faut certainement se
méfier
de toute façon on paye ce qu'on a c'est
clair alors faut pas non plus se laisser
manipuler je dirais par le par le
commerce aérien mais il y a un tarif
minimum qui est raisonnable qui
correspond à ce que vous payeriez en
voiture en train ou bon avec un
équivalent et là vous savez que vous
êtes à peu près en sécurité
ce jour de juillet 2012 est un jour très
spécial pour Bahia Bakari elle s'apprête
à prendre le train direction Marseille
c'est ici que se trouve la plus large
communauté comorienne de France et pour
aller à Moroni la capitale des Comores
il faut obligatoirement passer par
l'aéroport de la cité phocéenne pour
Baya ce voyage est important là ça va
au revoir
malgré les épreuves Baya a réussi à
garder une certaine insouciance mais
c'est surtout son courage qui étonne
prendre l'avion ne lui fait pas peur et
son secret c'est une foi inébranlable en
Dieu
avant mon accident
[Musique]
avec cet accident je crois vraiment mais
par moi-même pas parce qu'on m'a dit
c'est vraiment moi
un voyage en forme de pèlerinage sur la
terre de ses ancêtres
un retour aux sources pour Bahia qui
depuis son accident ce sent plus que
jamais attaché au Comores et aux
Comoriens
s'ils apprennent que je suis Gaïa enfin
il y a déjà qui se mettent à pleurer ça
les a beaucoup touchés jusqu'ici parce
qu'il y avait leur famille et tout le
monde se connaît donc ça a beaucoup
touché ce qui s'est passé
comme un symbole pour elle l'essentiel
est ailleurs
j'ai l'impression que ma mère on y pense
pas et je suis sûr que eux ils disent
bah oui
dans cet accident pense pas aux autres
qui sont partis le crash c'est pas moi
c'est les 152 personnes qui sont partis
et leur famille vient avec ça et on
parle pas de ces gens-là
[Musique]
pour ne jamais oublier le drame survenu
aux Comores en juin 2009 un monument aux
morts a été érigé à Moroni
mais désormais pour cette jeune fille de
16 ans il est temps de tourner la page
et de se projeter vers l'avenir
[Musique]
Baya et Thibault une adolescente et un
homme que tous ses parts
ils sont pourtant l'un comme l'autre la
preuve vivante qu'être rescapée d'un
cracher aérien ce n'est pas juste
survivre à un accident
c'est aussi de devoir trouver au
quotidien la force de réapprendre à
vivre
[Musique]
Thibault a réussi à refaire sa vie
sa petite fille Elena et sa femme Julie
l'aide au quotidien à aller de l'avant
mais il semble que le traumatisme de
l'accident dont il a été victime le Anta
jamais
tous les jours à chaque fois que je me
lève le matin ou à chaque fois que je
suis un pas j'ai des douleurs donc ça me
rappelle forcément l'accident mais ce
qui peut être assez difficile c'est
quand il y a de l'orage quand je passe à
côté des aéroports c'est vachement de
mal à côté d'Orly Roissy c'est
c'est quand même super dur pour moi de
passer à côté des aéroports c'est
surtout les bruits des odeurs ce qui
peuvent rappeler à n'importe quel moment
en fait l'accident
est encore jeune mais avec cette
expérience elle a acquis une sagesse et
une maturité qui devrait l'aider à
réaliser ses ambitions
[Musique]
c'est important de donner les moyens de
donner les moyens d'avoir un bon avenir
pas forcément de réussir parce que après
ça c'est parfois si on n'a pas de chance
voilà mais donner au moins les moyens
d'avoir un bon avenir
parce que voilà
ils sont pas toujours là pour s'occuper
de nous que nous aussi on va devoir
grandir voir nos enfants